Roman good morning guys so today is a
very exciting day for me because I'm
finally gonna get my hair done again but
by the time you guys see this you guys
are probably already seen my hair yeah
I'm excited I'm gonna cut my hair
shoulder length now and I'm gonna dye my
hair mint which is a color that I've
always wanted well I've always wanted
teal specifically but Julia's got her
blue hair and not I want to be a copycat
her so I'm going more in the mid side
and so I'm gonna go see my really good
friend Yuri and I'm so excited to see
here because I found out that she's
pregnant and she just found out that
she's pregnant too and I think she's
like a few months already like she
didn't know she was pregnant for some
time so I am so excited to go give her a
big hug and rub her belly and just be
there for her I'm just so happy and
especially because I know that this is
something she's always wanted and like
for her and her husband Pat and there's
just there's such good people and it's
just so good to see like your friends
like you really care about and like when
they have something that's very special
and like that it's like life-changing so
I'm gonna go see Yuri right now and I'm
gonna bring you guys along with me today
yay
[Music]
let me give you one last look real quick
one - bye-bye
I gotta go okay hard got my sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulation
oh my god it's great I don't really get
any signals or anything some of
everything falls normal do you have a
pregnant yet oh my god you could help
are you now four months
oh my god oh yeah you're a minty babe I
completely trust you you can make me
like me oh you got a girl you're gonna
look hot coming today - yeah just a
little human eats like an alien thing
yeah yeah yeah see muscle of you - I
can't see it I always think about them
they're not like that they for this is
so strange
there's no stream my sauces like you
know like on Facebook you always just
like those videos
but they said now that you find out it's
a way to process the baby outside the
room yeah he said in the tube so you
know how like surrogates kind of like
that but they can't make it into like so
sad you're too baby
what are we thinking I don't even like
there's actually moving achievement in
there nothing so whether it is more what
is that that's weird
the whole process of being pregnant is
the connection we took the woman's oh
yeah the baby they don't hear that were
like yeah I mean like what's the point
of they being the cube didn't know it
was you know those humans are cells it
has like no next yeah there's no they
mature
[Music]
[Music]
it's not pretty
you look like even more beautiful in the
past of it huh I'm cool you know like
this device yeah
[Music]
color something very very no I mean you
know we won't make it
sometimes when you put it on and shut up
it's a beautiful with the beautiful
Tiffany thank you and they're beautiful
you're a so do you know I thought so I
keep hearing it was a really [ __ ] up
yeah then he really saw it she touched
it in that's how do you guys what do you
guys think
I love it is it good good yeah I'm never
getting home I just took it out of a
bunch so looks
I love how your hair all weave gets up
early and like so voluminous and I'm
always like damn I should do it Roby
yeah I mean right now it looks kind of
crazy but so about I'll try to go superb
like not super about charcoal later
today but I'm have enough time so you're
just gonna go like a little layers yeah
I think it's a I think maybe my roots
I'm gonna try this be patient and let it
grow out yeah have a long beautiful hair
I do I miss my mom here I think before I
cut it it took me like three or four
years to grow it back Wow yeah and
they'll probably have it long maybe like
a few months and then I'm rubbing it
forward and they're coming they're all I
don't know how are you feeling what
you're gonna good I'm so like I did I
want to see the final product already
she's got it I'm like
and you just cuz I love cute little head
yeah nothing like I know what I'm
talking about I mean you know what you
got out of time
[Music]
Junior B is because that would take
eight would use for so like when he was
a baby
I remember AC gaming him a lot kisses in
one time he thought my nose no but I got
my three factions and the three I would
love like carrot blades down on the
floor caring
you always thought for myself I wouldn't
learn
because I'd be playing living like this
I'm really cool and you'll be laughing
you both in Oh cuz I feel like we
screwed up great yelling spit up
when you
No
[Music]
realize hearing difficulty here actually
yeah
yeah but heaven grab but I'm here longer
like
we're on the third path
once you finish this jail she's gonna
put the third one on and hopefully love
you my hairs being stubborn
so then woman grab onto the color you
look good
thank you thank you we see yours I know
vivica prior to the minor Phil rise up
[Music]
wait for you like it
experts when you're going back here like
Holly quick Harley Quinn are you reading
your book upside out but are you still
having a mommy that has crazy colored
hair I know you don't like your huh I
like it you didn't really like purple so
if it's purple you don't like your foods
okay you're trying to make it look yeah
gonna turn blue color my mother's hair
[Music]
you and Jo Jo
of course you'll never denied oh wow
cool I was trying not to copy Julie open
that up heavier they give up history but
you're like a teal
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god you like it feels good that's
hot they're like a different person now
who are you you fiance oh my god and I
have a new really like you every time
every time you say you want to change
your hair color always get so like candy
and like worried that it's not going to
turn out well
realize that everything is such a bold
decision to like color your hair but
it's fun and close by and if it doesn't
turn out okay and which I never doubt
that it will turn out okay because I
have like complete trust in URI and like
chill maker Wars one way or another so
make me look good
no now you're two for two but I think
very happy with both crazy colors you've
done so far
Thanks all right so now that we thought
our hair did and we're looking good
except Casey he he was supposed to get
her good today but then URI was like can
we move your playmates already you
swamped in yeah that girl worked way too
hard but neglected free she's like you
know but anyways but now we're about to
go eat some yummy ramen for lunch
[Music]
Maggie just practice the more you
practice the better you'll get if you
don't try you're never gonna learn I
think you don't have noodles or rice
you're explaining him why you don't do
that all right so Asian culture you
don't want the zoo staff here like this
and leave it there
they respect to the dead so if you were
to take this to a joke zone and a
graveyard it's like you getting food to
bed so and vice versa if you were to do
this at the dinner table that's like
inviting the dead to come eat with you
which is bad luck it's okay just keep
practicing you gotta close your top
stick when you pick it up close up and
then they'll help you grab it no no no
yes we've been open like Tong baby
oh my goodness
then he'll get lowered here please try
closing it together right
help you okay use your spoon with your
other hand
yeah good job
I think it's my turn
[Music]
so when I first met - there's just one
particular night I thought hey we should
go out and eat some ramen and then she
tells me once they have instant noodle
restaurants like my world
like other ethnicities are sprinkled in
with my bubble butt and so that's what
made me think that I grew up very
diverse but once I started meeting KP
that's my real life oh my goodness I was
in a book
[Music]
so we're showing up at the office at
about 6:40 p.m. to your morning coffee
and yeah where do you start today
Jerry yeah so generally we don't come to
the office until one of us has a meeting
and I didn't have any meetings today but
Casey does she has a meeting today at
7:00 so he made it just in time for his
meeting people yeah it's pretty cool
like especially on Fridays because we
don't film and because for the most part
we
it's kind of like a chill day in terms
of work so Fridays are my favorites
alright so now we're at the office and
barbell is having their meeting and I
think they're done so I'm gonna walk in
and see what they think
have you had
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think of my hair she looked
away she doesn't like it so I always
feel bad because I'm allergic to dogs
and I see the kind of happiness that
Tiff's and Isaac share with vaughn britt
and meatloaf and I'm just like I'm the
guy that's preventing them from enjoying
dogs I feel so bad but I'm allowed to
the dogs I can't help it I go I
literally cannot be around dogs for like
five minutes and I'll start wheezing and
then if they lick me I get I get rashes
and stuff tiffen Isaac for sure our dog
people I am NOT a dog person they get
their dog fixed whenever we hang out
with everyone else's dogs which is cool
but it you know that happiness and that
smile I see on her faces and I wish they
could experience that firsthand in the
comforts of our own home with our home
dogs but that day will probably have to
wait Isaac has a bright future I think
actually has a really bright future he's
gonna get older he's probably a move on
his own eventually and he can have his
own dog tip on the other hand she stuck
with me for the rest of her life not
helping you there
I think the first term I would they
started off with the other kind of
company which company those voyages more
healthier that Casey chose me probably
there's no cute I'm not making fun of
you just like your head movement